despite the fears of those ukrainian
troops the russian foreign minister has
repeatedly said that his country will
not invade sergey lavrov is expected to
meet his u.s counterpart anthony blinken
in coming weeks yes
there won't be a war as far as it
depends on the russian federation we
don't want a war but we won't let our
interests be rudely trampled on and
ignored
the us has rejected all the russian
security proposals for the last two or
three years now they're putting the same
things on the table in other words
they're borrowing from recent russian
initiatives this is something at least
baylor russian and russian militaries
will conduct joint drills next month
russia has been deploying extra soldiers
and fighter jets to its neighbor and
ally in a national address baylor
russian president alexander lukashenko
said that hundreds of thousands of
russian troops were ready to defend the
country
so will there be war or not yes there
will be but only in two cases
if direct aggression is committed
against belarus
if a hot war is unleashed against our
belarus
and the second possibility for war to
happen and for belarus to take part in
is if our ally the russian federation is
directly attacked if the same aggression
is committed against the territory of
the russian federation
well that's the diplomatic front in the
east for the story in the west let's go
live to paris al jazeera's natasha
butler is there uh president macron of
france has spoken to russia's president
what do we know of the call natasha
yes the french and russian presidents
had a phone call we're told by the
elysee that lasted about an hour we
don't have the details yet uh but we are
expecting uh to be briefed by elysee
spokes people a little bit later this
afternoon uh paris time what we know
though is we heard a little earlier from
france's foreign minister who said
really what the situation is is that the
ball he said is in russia's court and
what macron was hoping to get from this
telephone call uh we uh understand the
two main things one of course to try and
diffuse the crisis over ukraine to try
and persuade personally persuade if you
like uh president putin
to follow the path of diplomacy and not
of conflict macro also adamant that he
would give uh putin a very sen putin a
very clear message that of course if
russia was to invade ukraine then
western allies uh would respond uh with
severe sanctions uh the other thing
macro was hoping to do in this telephone
call is trying to understand exactly
what russia's intentions are is it
intending to ukraine russia certainly
invade ukraine russia certainly says it
has no intention to do so but macro
wants to know why is there such a troop
build up uh on the border more
transparency uh from moscow
natasha many thanks al jazeera's natasha
butler they're live in paris let's get a
little geographical context now russia
has troops and military equipment on its
border with ukraine to the north in
belarus where they due to take part in
war games and to the south in crimea
which russia annexed in 2014.
andreas krieg is with us in london he's
an associate professor in the defense
studies department at king's college
london and the author of surrogate
warfare the transformation of war in the
21st century good to have you with us
andreas does the number of troops that
russia has
currently stationed at ukraine's border
indicate to you that an incursion or
invasion is a distinct possibility as
the u.s says
well
it all depends on the political
objectives ultimately that russia has so
any campaign plan operational plan will
stem from the ultimate objective that
russia is trying to pursue is russia
ready to have a war in ukraine of course
it could do that but it comes at an
immense risk and especially in the land
warfare domain you know 100 000 troops
certainly looks a lot it would be a
combined
arms approach but it will come with at a
very high cost and with a lot of risks
also for casualties on both sides
because i think in the land warfare
domain particularly on the eastern and
northern flank of the ukraine the
ukraine is very fairly well defended
especially after training and and
supplies coming in from the west over
the last
seven eight years so it ukraine is a lot
more ready to defend itself now than it
was in 2014 but there is a weak
underbelly i mean the weak underbelly
and i think you've seen that on that map
is is really to towards the south now
with crimea being occupied by russia um
you know there is a possibility of um
you know the the russians using the
their advantage in the naval space or in
the air air power space so the naval
space would mean a merit a a maritime
landing uh and a a an amphibious landing
but this would be very difficult to do
and would also come with its own risk so
russia knows this will be a very high
cost escalation if they do so i also
would say that you know in terms of
logistics the russians are not really
yet ready yet to maintain a a campaign
into deep in ukraine because the
environment isn't as permissive i was
going to say a hundred thousand sounds a
lot but is it enough what is russia's
strategy here is it all about
uh pressuring the west and nato into
making concessions is it a good strategy
is it working or has russia
miscalculated
well i mean it's i'm still up for
speculation i also would say that the
kremlin really hasn't up it made up its
mind of what it is that it can achieve
really um i think belarus is a very
important point that you already um
stated in the initial video because here
we've seen the russians actually getting
into belarus after everything that
happened there over the last two three
years um and doing so without any
condemnation from the west it has
happened quietly because everyone is
focused on ukraine i think there is
already an objective that that russia
has achieved in terms of the negotiation
over whether ukraine would actually
never join nato which is the kind of the
request that the russians are making it
seems like the west is uh is really
diametrically opposed in their
objectives there doesn't seem to be an a
real um compromise at this point in time
that they can walk towards the problem
with the russians is they don't have
they haven't really created an off-ramp
for themselves for them to step away
from uh from this escalation into a
diplomatic realm um so it really depends
if a proper invasion and i mean a
multi-uh like a a combined arms
operation deeply into ukrainian
territory will be very very difficult um
if it's about toppling the regime in
kiev or toppling the political status
for creating chaos that can be achieved
through a variety of different means
which doesn't necessarily need an
invasion of 100 000 troops it can be
done through surrogates it can be done
in the information space through cyber
operations and it can be done by a very
small very
focused operation um in in eastern
ukraine but all of that will come with
huge economic costs for russia and it
will come with reputational costs for
russia as well and the question is is
that something that russia is willing to
bear is that a burden that russia is
willing to bear and i think negotiations
are already going in the right direction
i think what russia wanted to have
ultimately is having a common ground
with uh finding common ground with the
west to negotiate and i think they've
gotten this they're now sitting at the
table they are talking um and i think
that is probably what the russians are
trying to achieve i cannot imagine that
they are interested in a major combat
operation because nothing what russia
has done over the last 30 years would
prepare the military to actually conduct
an operation such as this andreas good
to talk to you many thanks indeed andres
creek there in london